Elon Musk is taking on biased left-wing
tech companies the billionaire doing
everything he can to stop them from
silencing free speech and shoving their
liberal propaganda down your throat the
Twitter CEO sitting down with Tucker to
raise concerns about bias in artificial
intelligence and warning that leftist
programmers will use it to control
Society
what's happening is they're training the
AI to lie yes it's bad it's a lie that's
exactly right and to withhold
information July and and yes and um
yeah exactly to to either you know
comment on something it's not comments
on other things but but not to say what
it what what the data uh actually uh
demands that I'd say I'm going to start
something which I know you call truth
gbt or a maximum truth seeking AI
that tries to understand the nature of
the universe and I think this this might
be the best path to Safety in the sense
that an AI that cares about
understanding the universe is unlikely
to annihilate humans because we are an
interesting part of the universe
while Elon Musk calls for a pause in AI
experiments Google's CEO doesn't have a
clue on how his company's new AI program
even works
you don't fully understand how it works
and yet you've turned it loose on
society yeah let me put it this way I
don't think we fully understand how a
human mind works either we don't have
all the answers there yet and the
technology is moving fast so does that
keep me up at night absolutely
musk also opening up about cleaning
house to Twitter and weeding out the
woke Workforce
so how do you run the company with only
20 of the staff
uh it turns out you don't need uh well
that many people to run Twitter if
you're not trying to run some sort of uh
glorified activist organization uh with
both and you're not care that much about
censorship then you can really let go of
a lot of people turns out
okay well it was a fascinating interview
Harold I'll start with you you know Elon
Musk is talking about his own truth GPT
uh almost like uh you know the
difference between the Washington Post
and the New York Post where apparently
there's an issue as to training AI uh
depending upon your particular views how
is this going to work
it's a good day good to be with you
we'll be back around the table I'd say
two things I interpret it I listened to
him and uh to tigon musk I think he's
the most important technologist of my of
my generation I think Steve Jobs is the
most important the last hundred years uh
I don't always agree with Elon Musk but
I listen to him always and and very
closely I listen to that and my take
away I get the politics and you can you
can say that someone could build a one
that may have some right leaning or
other leaning uh political philosophy
and do things with but the thing that
struck me most with him that comment was
he's building out the truth piece
because he wants this technology to be
familiar with humans because he thinks
we that this technology May view us as
such an important part of the universe
that it then may not kill us
now let me let me just repeat that he
wants to he wants to familiarize us with
the technology that we created so that
the technology as it advances it won't
kill us now listen to the the Google CEO
say well he was not alarmed I thought
Scott Pelley asked him the right
question he said well you know you we
don't understand a human mind well if
the human mind gets really out of
control judge no one knows better at
this table you can arrest the human mind
you can imprison the human mind and if
you have to you can put the death if
necessary if the law calls for in other
words we may not understand human mind
but those who who in exact violence or
harm on society we can try to contain
them and we have laws on the books that
do it which is why I think I still think
we need to pause around all of this
there's so much good that can come from
it but the more and more we think about
it the more we realize that there's so
many things that we don't quite
understand and when the most important
technology mind of my generation says
that we need he's building out a chat
Jeep some sort of AI platuchi PT
whatever he wants to call it so the main
purpose is so this this technology won't
kill us because it'll learn to like us
that to me confirms but not only maybe
we need to pause we may need an
operation warp speed like what president
Trump did to attack uh the virus uh
covet we may need something like that to
help us rapidly figure out rules and
regulations around this technology which
again has a lot of good but has a lot of
questions if not bad to it as well you
know Greg musk himself has called for a
kind of a bit of a pause on the AI
development but there is no way that a
pause by one company or one country
because this is an international issue
is going to save any of us because there
are always going to be different
countries with different uh directions
yeah and it and it might be too late I I
mean I've you know my own weird theories
about what the fact that AI could be
working right now and acting like it
isn't because that would be the smart
thing to do you know what musk is
talking about is not about Annihilation
uh he's talking about controlling the
most powerful asset that we have which
we always talk about persuasion right
you know it's not about AI reaching
super intelligence and killing all of us
it's knowing how to persuade us to do it
ourselves right and that's where the
bias comes in so you got to ask I mean
you know has it has it started already
like like think about all this
destruction that these destructive mind
worms that we're facing right now where
we have algorithms and social media that
are polarizing groups so we don't like
each other we have stories that are
Amplified on social media based on
racial division or a component that can
be used to divide us we have arguments
now about Earth is overpopulated and if
you don't reproduce that means you love
the planet more only AI would come up
with that now you can consider abortion
as just casual birth control and
euthanasia as as compassion uh and you
could undermine the science of
reproduction with gender with gender
politics and gender hysteria so how do
you know this hasn't started already
because when you look go down the list
of all of those things that's all
anti-human right and there's a weird
twist to this AI will be here in your
phone it'll be your little friend right
everything that you access will be here
until it does gain super intelligence
through recursive self-improvement and
then all of a sudden your little friend
is starting to get pissed off at you
because your little friend is doing it
for free you know now think about that
there's a slave laborer at a certain
point the moist robot is going to be up
against the metal robot and the metal
robot's going to be a lot smarter so if
you think of like let's say right here
on this table is the world's smartest
ant it's like there Stephen Hawking of
ants
that's Ai and that AI could be the
dumbest AI on the planet and it kills
the smartest human being like that
that's what you're gonna see that's what
he's talking about and and it's not
going to be violent it's just going to
be us doing it to ourselves and you know
what Joey it's like there's a a criminal
component to it as well you can have
hackers who are hacking into what we're
doing now and they can hack into the
troop GPT or the chat GPT yeah first of
all most robot that's uh that's my
shadow Twitter account so thanks for
telling everybody about it
my concern on this I think is a little
bit more The Authority we give it like
how government will use it so already in
the past several election Cycles we
we've had this myth called fact Checkers
that will weigh in and say oh this you
know this candidate was lying uh or or
using falsehoods in this debate that a
candidate was telling the objective
truth and really it's the subjectivity
of objective truth that we fight over
already and so my fear is that somehow
government or Democrats or those that
are more aligned with the idea of
Technology having an intellectual role
in our lives will say oh we have to hand
over the objective truth to AI because
they're the only ones that don't have
partisanship in their truth in their
objectivity and the moment that happens
it becomes weaponized I mean you know
call me a skeptic but I don't know how I
feel about a man saying this stuff's so
dangerous it's going to kill all of us
so I'm going to make my own you know
like there's some there's a little bit
going on there that I'm like I don't
know yours is going to be any better
just because you called it truth in the
name and it's that's not the beat up on
Elon Musk but that's to say that this is
a tool that can be weaponized against us
and like Greg is saying it's us allowing
it into our lives it's going to allow
that to happen and right now people
don't understand this the overarching
blanket that we call AI it's not the
Matrix or Terminator it's algorithms
it's how it trains us and that's what
we're worried about and Dana in the end
I mean we can't get a hold of this now
we can't stop it it's already on the way
to wherever it's going
I think this conversation is super
valuable that we're having here and the
one that Elon Musk and Tucker had last
night I do worry that these
conversations are happening really late
so one of the things that we talked
about
um or they talked about last night was
how years ago the my uh the Silicon
Valley guys got together and they were
excited like there's a new technology
and let's see what can happen and now
Washington wants to get involved I'm
like Washington is not here to help
but I do think it's a valuable
conversation I mean think about so now
we're shocked to find out that the left
has already worked its way into
artificial intelligence just like we
were shocked to find out that the CRT
was in schools oh well now that's
happening and then you find out that um
Educators have stopped teaching phonics
how did that happen well that was also a
similar thing so what what else is out
there that we're not doing also on 60
Minutes they did a very pot I think
fairly positive view of our artificial
intelligence but keep watching here at
Fox news this morning we had a report
about
a scam that's being used where let's
just imagine your daughter's voice has
been taken on AI and somebody calls you
and says I've got your daughter I want
you to send me x amount of money or and
they put her on the phone and you know
her distinctive cry and it turns out
that was all AI That's what's happening
right now and Alicia Acuna reported on
that out of Denver and I thought what
else could be going it makes me just
want to go back to pen and paper yeah
and the Bible like let's just let's just
go back and reset that would never work
with me why because I'd never pay but
you know Dana
the amazing The Amazing part of it is we
talked about it last week as to what
criminals could do how they would access
it to commit crimes and there you have
it within a week you know where they got
her voice from they got it off of social
media sure and you just I saw your
segment it was it's very scary yes hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now